a raffle person is an expert on
terrorism and crisis management the
German Institute for International and
security affairs here in Berlin well
welcome to DW um so what are we learning
about this the main suspect er Brent and
Tarrant well we don't have any
independent information yet on who this
person is self-described he is working
man an Australian who didn't go to
university and describes himself as a
average person who just believes in
racist white supremacist ideas and
thought he had to take action so
unfortunately I can't provide you with
any other further information now and it
is actually also I think responsible to
wait because as we heard from the police
there may be also another person
potentially involved it's been talk of
some sort of manifesto that he did it
published what have we heard about that
well this is true I would underline what
was just said about spreading material
and I'm thank goodness this isn't
available that easily anymore but yes
there is a 70 page something manifesto
where he sets out his worldview it's
actually quite savvy trying to speak to
different audiences sort of anticipating
a lot of questions of what is would be
asked about his motives and basically he
espouses this idea that there is a great
replacement that the white population
has to defend itself against other races
other immigrants that have a higher
birthrate that's as essential motivation
according to this manifesto there is a
similarity here between between this
attack and New Zealand and they have
attacked some years ago perpetrated by
Anders Breivik in in Norway you have two
countries where they're renowned for
being quite peaceful that are suddenly
rent by this sort of violent extremism
can one country learn from another well
if we can learn something from Norway
and then it was really to maintain an
open and free society because Norway
actually were acted very stabling I mean
everybody was shocked and there was a
great deal of mourning but there wasn't
a rush to sort of increase their
surveillance or it sort of having any
kind of further security measures in
place I mean the first responders had to
upgrade their their game but beyond that
I think the liberal defence the liberal
order of Norway was upheld and I think
and New Zealand should do the same the
the the perpetrator just apparently
chose New Zealand because a was
accessible and B apparently because the
church was it was previously a church it
was reconvey repurpose into a mosque and
that was something he saw as a symbolic
target beyond that I don't think there
is a reason why New Zealand was attacked
it's interesting you you you make that
point about about Norway we heard from
emerges into a her and they're saying
that that New Zealand will not be
changed by this attacks but countries
are certainly here in in Europe where
these attacks have happened you see a
much greater police presence
you see suspicion on the streets but
that didn't happen in Norway not in the
sense that there was a presence on the
street with armed guards or that there
was a push for more intelligence about
surveillance but this is not to say
there are things to be done and I think
in particular in this instance this will
renew the debate about the
responsibility or the possible role of
platforms where this kind of information
is shared the the attack was
live-streamed this was unfortunately a
new thing and I fear this may be not the
last time so that's the debate we have
to have but that doesn't mean that we
should step back from a free and open
society where we roundly condemn all
sorts of racism and this extremism and
and on that debate is there more that
platforms like Facebook again I can or
should do when events like this our life
strained in this way it's not something
that can be asked very quickly I mean
the European unit for example is at the
moment considering a law to force
platforms to take down content within an
hour if it's been declared terrorist and
then otherwise they would incur heavy
fines and that does potentially make
sense in the context like this but on
the other hand of course that raises
again the question is that realistic
isn't it already out when it's out and
then it's shared anyway what was the
risk of censorship so that debate is not
at the end yet but I think we still are
in the process of finding balance these
platforms moving in earlier and I think
that's certainly something that needs to
be done also in the process of
radicalization but also not going so far
to say we have to take out everything
the minute it appears
good talking to you thank you for
joining us Rafaela bus honking the
German Institute for International and
security affairs thank you